[Music]
if you watch our videos you know we love
dissonance and today we'll go on a
little adventure we want to know which
dissonance character are you and at the
end of the quiz we'll reveal the results
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe to the things now let's
get to the video first question is
pretty simple
what's the color of your eyes a green be
dark brown C Brown d blue if you
answered a you get ten points if you
answered B you get 20 C you get 30 nd
you get 40 don't forget to write those
points down fun fact did you know about
Jays eyes change color in descendants in
the descendants wicked world series
his eyes were green but in the movies
they're brown okay on to the next
question second question is also simple
but we promise it'll make sense later
how old are you a 16 be older than any
of these C 14 D under 14 if you answered
a you get 10 points B you get 20 C you
get 30 and D you get 5 third question
who is your favorite Disney villain a
Maleficent be Ursula C karela de ville
de Captain Hook
if you answered a you get 10 points B
you get 20 C you get 30 and D you get 40
but in fact time did you know that
Maleficent design was based off three
things the devil bats and random
designed an illustrator found in his
house and yet she's still iconic okay
next question
now this one is a tough one fourth
question pick your favorite Disney
Princess a Princess Aurora be Ariel see
Snow White D none of these four answer a
you got 10 points for answer B you get
24 answer C you get 30 and four answer D
you get five fifth question is slightly
easier choose your favorite color
a purple the blue C red D green
e white for answer a you got 10 points
for answer B you get 34 answer C you get
40 for answer D you get 20 and for
answer e you get five next question
might be a little bit harder pick one
location
a castle B auradon prep Steve pirate
ship
an island ii dragon hall if you answered
a give yourself 10 points B is 20 C is
30 D is 40 and E is 5 did you know that
are done craft is a boarding school and
yet some of the heroes that live nearby
still attend it it's obviously pretty
popular with everyone next question is
interesting what's your favorite Disney
movie a Sleeping Beauty be snow white
see Peter Pan D Little Mermaid II 101
Dalmatians if you picked the answer a
give yourself 10 points 20 points for
answer being 30 points for answer C 40
points for answer D and E is 5 next
question
pick one of these strengths a love B
confidence C charm D loyalty e
intelligence
speaking of love you should definitely
follow dub Cameron on Twitter because
she always talks about how much she
loves her fans and encourages people to
be as confident and as positive as
possible a few more questions pick a
subject at school a heart
v chemistry C math d recess e PE and
last but not least pick one of these
Dodi ak signs a Aries B Leo C Capricorn
D Scorpio e Gemini if your answer is a
you get 10 points 20 points for B 30
points for C 40 points for D and 5
points for e are you ready to find the
results total up all your answers if
your score is anywhere between 40 and 55
your Jay your handsome and athletic you
don't trust a lot of people but you
eventually learn to appreciate the value
of teamwork you use your charms to get
what you want or better yet get who you
want but you're still a loyal person if
your score is anywhere between 60 and 95
points your mouth a natural-born leader
who's stubborn and fierce you're
strong-willed and know exactly what you
want you might not like school but that
doesn't mean you don't learn about
things that interest you your favorite
subject is art and you're naturally a
very creative person if your score is
anywhere between 100 and 115 you're
Carlos you always trust everyone and
follow the rules you might be scared of
everything but your love for animals set
you apart from anyone else your friends
are your
Emily and you have no problem being
there for anyone if your score is
anywhere between 120 and 200 your Eevee
your incredibly gorgeous and charming
you can make friends with just about
anyone you meet your favorite subject is
chemistry and you love to experiment
with new ideas you're a social butterfly
if your score is anywhere between 205
and 270 your umma a fierce leader who
loves to be sneaky you're loyal to your
friends even though people rarely listen
to you people might think you're
naturally a very cold person but the
truth is you can only open up to your
family and friends you're misunderstood
but you never back down from a challenge
if your score is anywhere between 275
and 390 you're Harry you're a loyal
friend and you have no problem standing
up to people you're spontaneous and love
to go on adventures you don't like to be
laughed at and you're quick to purge but
you're still one of the most loyal and
charming people around do you want to
know what we got we're Emma let us know
who you are in the comments and if you
agree with this choice and that's all
for our video don't forget to subscribe
to the things and tell us how you felt
about this video thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]